this video is sponsored by ridgewallet
one piece is punk hazard
the 26th arc i've covered a tale that
spans 46 chapters that
honestly felt a little like 86 chapters
but you know what
now that i finished it and had the
correct amount of time to digest
everything that happened i think i
understand what oda was trying to do
with and in many ways succeeded in doing
with this gassy boy
last week i covered the treacherous
depths of fishman island and dealt with
some really heavy themes and characters
so i was in need of something a little
less intense and something a bit more
traditional in terms of one piece
storytelling
thankfully i got that with this but it
isn't all good
in the frozen misty fiery tundra of punk
hazard
and today i plan on exploring it from
top to bottom explaining myself
in full and so without further ado i'm
totally not mark and these are my first
impressions of thoughts on and review
for my very first steps into the brave
new world of one piece
this is the long-winded the intense and
at times
extremely clever punk hazard
[Music]
i'll do classical gas
punk hazard is a funny one on one hand i
found myself enjoying it towards the end
and the beginning but for a section of
the story that wasn't super small i
found myself dreading the next page turn
and worrying about composition way more
than i thought i would
yeah you heard me composition i'll
explain what i mean a little more
clearly later on but
for now generally i will say that as
arcs in one piece go
i thought this was pretty good i'm happy
i read it but i thought it suffered from
pacing issues during its telling as well
as some clarity issues as i said
regarding page composition and dialogue
but more specifically in essence this is
a pretty standard one piece story
they stumble upon a new somewhat
troubled island before they get caught
up in rabbit holes and traps that are
much more treacherous than they
anticipated there's some really great
action wonderful character exchanges and
some genuinely fantastic surprises that
honestly caught me more off guard than
any other swerve that might have been in
the series
maybe and once again as oda often does
the story kicks off in an incredibly
strong and interesting way as readers
and audience members at this stage in
the story we are primed for enjoyment
and excitement
we've been waiting a very long time to
at long last get to the new world of one
piece inhabited by the very emperors of
the sea themselves
and lord knows we want to get revenge on
a kaino and blackbeard for all the stuff
they've done
[Music]
and so thanks to those feelings that are
obviously in us right now
we are already excited to see what comes
next and
trust me oda is completely aware of all
of this
kicking things off with an extremely
character rich albeit slightly
understated character interaction on the
sunny
nami taking her eyes off the boys for 10
minutes to have a shower
leads to them almost getting eaten by a
giant fish and getting sucked into a
vortex and it's isolated moments like
this that i really do appreciate where
we get to see and experience the
dysfunctional family the straw hats have
ultimately become
and what's also great is that one piece
likes to take moments of reprieve to
just bask in the world it's created too
you see immediately after following this
instance
the crew in a moment of wonder become
surrounded by giant whales the same
species as laboon which is kind of
awesome because if no one told me that
they had been on the other side of the
red line now
i know that they were by virtue of the
fact that i know that these whales are
indigenous to this specific
area of the world and i know this
because the story told me this
hundreds of chapters ago it's instances
like this one i experienced while
reading
that puts into my mind stark clarity of
how much i've absorbed
regarding this world and its world
building it's a really unique and
wonderful feeling knowing that we are
exploring a story that's consistent and
alive
but all is not well and using this
moment of cam to immediately contrast to
one of mystery and tension
the calms on the sunny its services in
the new world immediately start to pick
up an sos signal from an
unknown island not pointed to by any of
their log poses in their possession
which on its own is rather interesting
and leads them down
a series of rabbit holes of discovery
and adventure but let's take a moment to
consider
something else first or at least i will
this piece of information sort of took
me by surprise so
it's theory time at this point in the
story we've gotten into a routine of
sailing
looking at the log pose pointing to the
next island chilling out on that island
for a bit and then repeating the
sequence
but punk hazard was different
this was an island that if the sos
hadn't been picked up on their [ __ ]
would never have been discovered by
luffy and his crew and what's even more
curious is that smoker later in the
story doesn't have a problem finding the
island at all which leads me to believe
that there might be islands that can't
be found unless the government so
chooses
and here's my theory the secrets that
the world government are so hell-bent on
hiding
could be concealed on an island that
cannot be discovered by either
anyone because the poses have been
destroyed or strictly by higher ups in
the world government perhaps even the
one piece is there
but yeah it's just a theory for now but
totally possible right regardless
luffy and the crew follow this distress
signal to punk hazard the very first
island of the new world
and it's friday night
it's on fire there's someone to be
rescued there smoker was listening to
their entire conversation and is now in
pursuit of them
and if that wasn't already tense enough
once luffy zorro usop and robin go to
investigate the island a little bit more
while the others stay on the ship
this happens this dragon fight was
way more fun than i thought it was going
to be and to be perfectly honest
sprinkled in enough mystery to hold my
attention almost
immediately so naturally when luffy does
pull an embodied pair of legs off of
this dragon i was left scratching my
head a little bit
as the legs effectively communicated
through
farting yeah you heard me right the the
legs communicated through farting that's
a real sentence i just said
jokes aside though i love the beginning
of punk hazard it takes advantage of our
expectations of how we think the arcs
are going to play out
and creates an entirely different
experience unlike the other arcs that
introduce us to the wildlife inhabitants
and cultures of the given area first
punk hazard is a little different the
island was once upon a time a
government-run facility led by dr
vegapunk
a person that's mentioned almost as
often as luffy and yet we still haven't
seen them in person yet
however since a particular series of
events changed everything that i will
absolutely be talking about a little bit
more later this island is now recognized
as a wasteland by the government that no
longer uses it
and with this knowledge when it becomes
apparent that there's something much
much more sinister going on in this
abandoned island
the contrast is striking back the ship i
honestly love this moment because it
establishes a bunch of different things
including the antagonists of the ark
itself
but also gives us a goal beyond
exploring witches for the gang to
regroup
and in this effort we get to understand
to become exposed to a host of new and
mysterious circumstances
like this little guy's head chopped up
into pieces in the same cell that they
were held in
clearly this is the headpiece of the
samurai puzzle that luffy and the others
began a scene ago
which adds even more purpose behind them
reuniting there and then
this little samurai guy needs to find
the rest of his body so might as well
help him oh wait he's a massive
douchebag
and this particular samurai's name is
dad
this i'm determined to get through a
single video without mispronouncing a
name by the way and to be honest things
only get more interesting from here
frankie burst them out of the cell using
his weaponry and lasers which is
awesome but once they do get out my
confusion went from a seven
to a ten i have several questions
so yeah this story might answer a
question here and there but
my god if it isn't hell-bent on laying
down ten new questions for every one it
answers
and to be honest it makes sense why it
unravels things the way it does too
punk hazard is in every sense of the
word a setup arc for the one to
immediately follow it but that's not to
say that it doesn't have anything to
offer on its own either
in a lot of ways this arc deals with
themes of accountability responsibility
and consequence and in exploring these
themes we see our main characters
interact with some truly chilling and
heartwarming characters creating
wonderful moments like when sanji cast
his pride to the wayside to embrace his
humanity by helping out this snarky but
defenseless
samurai and let's not forget about the
damn kids nami decides that despite it
being near impossible to escape these
jumpsuit-wearing goons that are pursuing
them out of this facility
nami feels an overbearing level of
responsibility for these little
and not so little children who are
begging for her to save them
but perhaps most interestingly we
discover some fascinating tidbits
regarding the history of this island
thanks to the main focus of this arc and
the main villain
caesar the clown mad scientist of the
now defunct
punk hazard facility i turned myself
into a pickle morty
and it's at this point the story splits
into five different subplots though
really there are two major ones and
these two major ones should be obvious
at this point the first being team luffy
comprised of himself
robin zorro usopp and the samurai legs
as they try to find the rest of him now
the second major point of view comes in
the form of team nami
who were just captured and are now stuck
within the facility of punk hazard with
her
is sanji frankie chopper and the
disembodied talking head of the samurai
oh and now a whole bunch of children
apparently in addition to this there are
three other points of view that
sort of vary in importance one is that
of caesar the clown as he reacts and
makes plans surrounding his experiments
and deals with the sudden appearance of
the straw hat crew
there's also smoker tashigi and the g5
troops
and finally there's brook who was left
in the ship when the others were
kidnapped
probably because they thought he was
dead and to be honest
his part of the story while minor it
does play a large role in the story in
terms of structure
he is literally the only reason team
luffy find out about what happened to
the rest of the crew
and the sunny and to be honest so far
everything in the story is
working for me there's some tight pacing
thanks to some well-placed minor fight
scenes
some really interesting mysteries and
now we have a goal to supplement
multiple points of view
it's all gravy and that's when a bloody
fascinating piece of info is dropped
you see all this time we've been on this
island a large part of the conversations
surrounding it have been about
why it's so icy and why it's so fiery at
different parts of it
and we learned this visually by way of
nami noticing the clouds above the fiery
hellscape we were initially presented
with and then of course that's confirmed
in the scenes with brooke so how did
this island come to be the way it
is fiery on one side and icy on the
other well
smoker answers that question and the
best part about this
is that it makes perfect sense in fact
it makes so much sense that if you or i
were in the right frame of mind when
looking at this question
there's a good chance that we could
actually answer it for ourselves because
we were given the answer back on fishman
island back then we were told about a
vicious battle that was held between
akainu and okiji competing for the right
to be the new fleet admiral
it happened about a year ago and lasted
10 days and would you know it punk has
it was a sight of that very battle
and since the battle's completion has
been in a constant state of hot and
cold i love this not only because we
could have picked up on it given that
piece of visual information
but punk hazard as we know is an island
not pointed to by any of the log poses
it's been abandoned for quite some time
and it's very close to the new hq
of the navy like everything about this
sudden new piece of information
really felt like someone putting the
last piece of the jigsaw in place
it made perfect sense and made some
really interesting lore surrounding the
island of punk hazard
and that's only part of the small
island's history as three years before
that very fight a massive explosion
happened that wiped out life in the area
this was the reason why oukiji and
akainu fought there in the first place
and that very explosion on that day is
one of the mysteries that's explored in
this act too
how did the catastrophe happen and if
that wasn't enough smoker arrives on the
supposedly abandoned island
knocking on the door and wouldn't you
know who opens it but
law this was the last person i expected
to be involved in this situation and
once again added even more curiosity to
the occasion
at this point in the story i had seen a
disembodied samurai battlefield set
ablaze by long complete battles
dragons giant children and a little more
recently i've seen luffy punch a centaur
in the schnaaz
this arc was bananas with a capital b
and now we are being reintroduced to
trafalgar law
now a war of the sea as it looks like he
might be involved with the goings-on
on the island but this story isn't
perfect and it does have its flaws and
one of those flaws that came to my
attention around this time surrounded
the equipment of usa no matter what the
circumstances are
you best believe that he has some random
thing perfectly specific for this
occasion
in his arsenal of random gadgets and
projectiles now this isn't a huge issue
but it did irk me a little bit because
we aren't made aware of the materials he
has from the get-go it comes across as
convenient more than anything else and
when something convenient comes out of
nowhere it just feels lazy the character
of usopp explains his supplies by saying
that all sorts of strange things were on
the island that he was training on
but without telling us what it is that
he found it just feels like a random
grab bag of whatever the team needs to
get out of this situation in a pinch
and that's fine i guess but it's
significantly less interesting than what
we had before
with him trying to figure out his way
around different opposites while also
knowing what he has and what he's
capable of like remember his fight with
luffy or
arlon's grunts or heck even this battle
with perona these fights specifically
worked because we knew what was in his
arsenal and the fun came from how he
bluffed or came up with amazing new ways
of using this sandbox of abilities we
all knew he had
so i think that's something that at
least for right now
new world usopp is missing for me
another convenience i noticed was that
the sos signal that led the straw hats
to the island in the first place really
was
another one of pure coincidence i was
hoping that it was a trap set by someone
that wanted something from them or
anything nefarious really but it was
again pure happenstance the centaurs
that luffy decked earlier were being
attacked by the samurai that they
encountered in the cell
and thus they in desperation made this
distress signal had this not happened
luffy and the crew wouldn't have found
this island at all
again these things aren't anything major
but it doesn't feel as well thought out
or as tightly told as the stories like
alabasta or skypia were for me now let
me be clear
at this point in the story i am still
all in and to be honest it was easy for
me to turn a blind eye to these issues i
had
especially when this happens to smoker
as he was talking to law at the door of
the facility
all right so we get the first
convergence of different narrative
threads now and boy is it interesting
as love finally shows us the powers of
his devil fruit ability swapping the
minds of the straw hats running past in
an instant
before removing all of the communicators
from the navy present in law taking this
course of action we learned that
whatever's happening on this island is
top secret and that no one can know that
he's there
again this is all interesting stuff and
what's more is that this is followed by
another great action sequence which i
gotta be honest
this arc is filled with i enjoyed almost
every fight in this arc more than what
we got on fishman island and i have no
idea if that's a controversial take but
there it is the fight that takes place
is that of law versus smoker who is at
this time
a vice admiral in the navy having been
promoted from captain over the last two
years
this particular fact is small but i
really like how we are not only seeing
the progression of the main characters
but also the secondary and territory
characters like smoker aokiji akainu
and even tashigi who has been promoted
to fill the position of captain that
smoker vacated
and during this fight between smokey and
drafty in addition to smoker's grit and
determination being on full display with
some great choreography
seriously this is like the best smoker
fight in the series so far he also
implements a sea prism tipped weapon to
fight law with
which not only is cool but given the
fact that smoker is also a devil fruit
wielder it serves to communicate his
confidence in his own abilities to hold
onto
this weapon such that it can't be used
against them small inclusions like that
are subtle but they go a long way in
helping to communicate an individual
character to an audience
but to cut a long story short law using
the op-op fruit abilities takes out
smoker's heart from his chest before
swapping his mind with tashigi
also speaking of mind swaps i think now
is a good time to discuss the
mind-swapping aspect of this story
[Music]
this video is brought to you by
ridge.com tnm most people are still
using wallets designed in the 1990s and
in this modern landscape
it's seriously outdated and i should
know i've been using the same wallet
since i was 15 years old and that means
i've been using some outdated wallet for
the last 14 years of my life
in the same way phones have gotten more
practical and compact over the last few
decades so too have wallets and
it's honestly made a massive difference
to my pockets personally i hate having
cumbersome items in there and this
totally fits my new lifestyle
it holds up to 12 separate cards plus
room for cash and there's over 30
different colors and styles including
carbon fiber and burnt titanium to
choose from
and if that wasn't enough to win you
over yet check out their thirty thousand
five star reviews the durable nature of
each of these wallets comes with a
lifetime warranty so
in theory you could buy this one wallet
and carry it for life and the rich team
have told me that they're so confident
that you like it that they'll actually
let you test drive it for 45 days that
means you can send it back for a full
refund if it's not up to your own
standards
right now there's a special offer going
where you can get 10 off
with free worldwide shipping and returns
and you can get all of this by going to
ridge.com
tnm and using the coupon code tnm
link is in the description
what is that a merman no it's a panda
shark with a man in his mouth i find
that hard to swallow
that's what she said
[Music]
this mine swap plotline while it makes
sense
doesn't do anything in the story except
delay its events from unfolding at first
it's funny watching chopper struggle
inside the body of sanji and watching
frankie struggle inside the body of
chopper but for every nami inside of
frankie's body to laugh at there's a
sanji inside of nami's body and a smoker
instead of tishigi's body that's only
there for fan service
and when i say this i'm not saying that
they are never funny sometimes they are
specifically the way smoker purely out
of habit and comfort
insists on sitting with his shirt open
in tashigi's body but for me
this gets old really fast and ultimately
with everyone whose minds have been
swapped
because they aren't used to the bodies
of their crewmates every task they need
to achieve becomes a punchline or
extremely annoying to get through
and that's not even the worst part so
nami is in frankie's body right
frankie is in chopper's body sanji is in
nami's body and chopper is in sanji's
body
now to some of you that might not sound
super complicated to understand but
when you have all of them arguing in the
same scene surrounded by all the
different characters and children
suddenly it becomes incredibly confusing
so much so that in the middle of one of
these chapters
oda makes them wear these masks of their
actual character in order to avoid
confusion
not to mention a sharp uptick in the
number of characters drawn into the
speech bubbles that they are speaking in
simply there to help the readers
remember who is in what body i have no
idea if this is easier to follow in the
anime but in the manga it got pretty
annoying in part specifically when the
straw hats regroup
adding even more talking heads to the
mix or at least i felt this way and this
brings us to the second act of the story
and
in this part i really started to find it
difficult to get through for the first
time ever reading this manga in fact
and this is why while i could read and
get through all of the information
relatively easy
it was by no means easy to understand
what's happening or going on just by
looking at these pages there's tons of
text tiny panels and so much conflicting
imagery that when you look at it
your brain might not know what's
happening on it without reading through
it and okay i can already hear a lot of
you say well
obviously you're supposed to read it it
has words it's a manga after all and i
totally understand that point of view
that means it's a visual medium as much
if not more than it is a written one
and in this instance i really don't
think oda was making the most out of the
visual components
of this media so often he leans so much
on the words rather than the drawings to
speak for themselves
and speaking of the text so much of the
text propagated throughout these
chapters are
flavor with characters saying
inconsequential stuff or reacting to
things that only
serve to make the conversations feel
more authentic and in many instances i
can totally appreciate stuff like that
it's a large part of what makes this
series as successful and immersive as it
is
but there's a time and place for
everything and when i turn the page and
i'm faced with this useless
text and a panel structure that isn't
intuitive it makes me not want to read
as much as i could and just for
argument's sake i'm going to demonstrate
what i think good panel structure is i'd
like to point you guys to these random
pages from early dragon ball z
while dragon ball was by no means as
narratively complex
or competent as one piece visually i
believe dragon ball is on another level
narratively
to many other manga not just one piece
manga is a visual format and akira
toriyama used this format to the best of
its ability in order to communicate
to his audience what he wanted to do on
a given page with clarity and a panel
structure that would suck
anyone into reading it now i get that a
lot of people might want the dialogue
and clutter panel structure because they
feel it gives more information to them
and that's
what they're after and i can totally see
that point of view but i can only speak
from my own point of view and personally
i don't see why we can't have both
heck one piece from the first chapter
through to eddie's lobby was paneled
extremely well
so i see no reason why it can't be like
that again with some minor alterations
and some smart use of paneling
these pages could be so much more
visually engaging while sacrificing
almost nothing in terms of story but
alas that wasn't the case with these
chapters and as a result
it felt more difficult to get through
this arc than any other i had read
through in the past
and to be honest this is a shame because
they actually really enjoyed a ton of
things that were going on in this arc i
liked how the focus of the air kept
shifting as new and exciting things came
to the forefront
like at this point in the story the team
reunite and split into three groups
nami and chopper stay with the kids who
are going through withdrawals from the
drugs that caesar gave them
yeah you heard me right this is an art
that deals with drugs then there's the
team of sanji brook and zoro who ran out
after the samurai looking for his kid as
sanji himself felt responsible for his
well-being which
i honestly really enjoyed and finally
the team of luffy usopp robin and
frankie who venture off to find the lab
to confront caesar about the children
and the shocking symptoms that they are
exhibiting
after his care and in retaliation to
this caesar enlists the work of the yeti
brothers giant hunters in this icy
tundra we've not yet
seen before and as i mentioned moments
ago these guys only present an issue to
the straw hats because they are after
getting their bodies swapped
and don't know how to fight in these new
ones punk hazard in the same way fishman
island wanted to handicap the straw hats
by surrounding them in water has
handicapped them in this way by
swapping their minds so in other words
the straw hats haven't had a single
worthwhile challenge since the return to
shabbat
and perhaps that's why i've enjoyed
fights with the dragon and smokers so
much
one is a novelty and the other doesn't
involve the straw hats at all
but we do get some interesting
information out of this exchange as
these yetis pursue and hunt for the
straw hats
they shoot brown beard in the face
execution style with these massive
cannons point blank
before stealing nami away in frankie's
body and i like this because they
actually steal frankie's body for two
reasons
firstly because he has the tech from dr
vega punk which is valuable
and they want to use him as bait to lure
luffy and the other prime targets in
which i thought was really good strategy
considering they had no chance once
luffy actually arrived to save her
that is if luffy even had to fight them
this section here is the single most
important part of the arc and to be
honest really piqued my interest back to
the levels of excitement
law moves to luffy and asks whether or
not he would like to form an alliance
up until this point i had been under the
impression that given law was working
alongside caesar
and his mad experiments and that given
he's a warlord of the sea
he would be firmly in the corner of the
already established side
and forces of caesar and punk hazard but
that's far from the truth
law is on his own side and no one else's
he explains that luffy and he have a
common goal right now and that together
they could take down an emperor of the
sea which
is a massive thing to say still at this
point of the story and in typical luffy
fashion
he agrees to the proposal and elects to
form an alliance with law despite the
crew
begging him not to
yeah so okay here's the lowdown
caesar's hell bent on getting these kids
back to conduct further weird
experiments on
he also acts as this godlike figure to
his subordinates gaining their trust
and he has this massive demonstration
planned in order to sell his work on the
black market to someone who goes by the
name of joker
something law mentioned is that caesar
is the only one that can produce this
chemical compound called
sad used by some extremely important
people in the black market that he again
sells through a vendor called joker who
becomes
extremely important later and i'll get
to that together the forces of luffy the
straw hats and law have to work together
in order to stop
all of this from happening and to save
the little kids and since law is on
their team he switches chopper back into
his body
frankie back into his and nami into
sanji's body because he's still out with
zoro and brook
looking for the samurai which they do
eventually find this is where the story
started to pick up for me again
there's a little bit of will they won't
they with sanji's group still out in the
wilderness some place and there's a
clear goal now after being established
help the kids and stop caesar so let's
see how punk hazard stuck the landing
so it comes to light that this caesar
guy was responsible for why this island
punk hazard became deserted in the first
place
apparently four years ago against dr
vega punk's wishes
he blew up the facility and showered the
area in poison destroying most life
and he alone survived unscathed because
of his devil fruit ability
and this conclusion i actually enjoyed
but there are still
aspects to it that i thought could have
been improved greatly and
once again it came in the visual clarity
department and at this point i feel like
i should reiterate that i am not
criticizing the anime's visuals here i
simply haven't seen it
i am just commenting on my experience
with the manga this week
and once luffy law and all the other
straw hats with the samurai converge on
the base from various points
things started to feel a little
cluttered and messy again for me now of
course during this time a lot of stuff
is happening sanji in an act of
selflessness rescues the samurai's body
from below the water locating it using
his haki and there are plenty of really
interesting and cool moments where haki
is used by both zoro and sanji in this
story which i really liked
luffy and law joined forces with smoker
but ultimately get captured joker's
revealed to be da flamingo
caesar plans to do some weapons
demonstration using some freaky gas to
kill everybody that no one can touch
and it's invading the compound okay look
long story short this is all bad stuff
happening and it basically translated to
all the straw hats and law in a
situation where they need to capture
caesar alive
and cannot get touched by this gas all
the while trying to save a bunch of
giant savage
children suffering from a bad come down
so yeah all things considered not
super bad that is until we meet this guy
okay so this is a bit of a bigger
problem this guy is tough and ends up
picking a fight with a bunch of them in
this effort and
to be honest the fights in this section
were the only aspects from it that i
really enjoyed and stood out for me
whether it be luffy's two decisive
encounters with caesar
sacking him in the face sanji cracking
his [ __ ] against virgo shin
or even smoker-in-law's altercation with
virgo and law ultimately getting the
upper hand in the end
this section if nothing else reinforces
that the new generation is here and
it's their time and this is abundantly
evident with the characters like usab
chopper and frankie who throughout this
story
get plenty of wonderful moments to shine
too and so now it's time to discuss some
of the aspects i
didn't really enjoy caesar as a villain
didn't do it
really at all for me he came across as a
two-dimensional cartoon villain that
didn't really
click i knew he offered no challenge to
luffy really and
his motivation and justifications for
what he has done did seem
far too outlandishly devious to even be
remotely credible for me i mean he
seriously looks like he should be from
one of those old hanna-barbera cartoons
from the 60s
and not in a good way one thing i
thought that i was really going to enjoy
was the keep away nature of this set
piece for the conclusion
given that they were all in an enclosed
space with the gas slowly filling up the
various chambers i thought the manga did
a pretty poor job visually of informing
us about the area
in the past i thought oda did a
brilliant job at establishing the areas
like alabasta in his lobby skype at
barite
arlan park and all the other places that
we were introduced to in these scenes i
was never left scratching my head
wondering where they were would anyone
please tell me because i could tell by
the context clues
but this compound laboratory situation
in this arc is
very boring and everything looks the
exact same and in the same way oda had
to make the others wear masks because
the things weren't clear enough when
they swapped their bodies
in this section we have to look at map
after map after a map of the area in
order to understand or have any sense of
where people are fighting and where
everyone is in relation to each other
and the only rooms that look
somewhat distinct are the sad room and
the control room and almost no fighting
takes place in these rooms beyond law
smoker and virgo situation that
again doesn't last very long needless to
say despite liking the concept behind
this section
despite liking the gas idea to create
tension and despite
all the effort that went into it i
thought the environment chosen in this
instance really held it back from what
it could have been
now this is obviously just my impression
from reading the manga
and who knows i might react differently
to how it was portrayed in the anime
but as of right now i was ecstatic to
finally be leaving the facility and
braving the outside world as the crew
law
g5 smoker and tashigi all escape with
their lives from the place
and again the fights that took place in
this compound were fantastic i loved
luffy's altercation
i really liked what smoker and law were
doing together and when law eventually
cut down virgo that was really
impressive
once again highlighting that this new
generation's time has finally come
that they are ready to compete with the
big boys but now we're coming to what i
think was probably the most shocking
part of the entire story
you see there's a section of this that
leans heavily on the devil fruit
abilities of trafalgar law you see he
has this ability as it's already been
established to remove a part of someone
from their bodies while also keeping
them alive and using this ability many
people in this story have their hearts
removed
from their bodies like smoker and law's
very own and in an effort to prove his
allegiance to caesar he gives his own
heart to him
in exchange for monets now one character
i didn't really speak about during this
video was that of a character happy lady
called monet she appears very early on
and she's effectively a subordinate of
caesar and virgo during this particular
section it was explained to us that in
order to gain caesar's trust
law offered up his own heart in exchange
for monets
taking out both of them and offering up
his own to caesar
as collateral in essence putting his
life in caesar's hands
this whole thing was basically to act as
a truce of sorts during the story now
this was established before the final
act like this was known going into the
final battle but this
was genius as when caesar was lying
outside the compound
after being punched into oblivion and
betrayed by law he still had the heart
given to him by law
and while this is happening monet is
about to blow up the lab in the same
devastating fashion
caesar did four years ago per his
instructions orders her to do this and
as she moves to flip the switch
caesar in a moment of anger stabs the
heart of smoker
but nothing happens as it turns out
the heart he has given to caesar wasn't
smoker at all
but monet's and thus caesar's undoing
was his own
i freaking loved this little swerve and
never saw it coming at all
and something i also like in this part
is caesar's motivation to not
kill law right away once he figures out
that he's after turning on him because
he already has a built-in desire
to kill him by using this new gas that
he's developed to show to the criminal
underground of the world
and to be perfectly honest that as well
as the conclusion of this arc really
helped it finish strong
now that law has in his possession
caesar wearing some sea prism shackles
that usopp managed to swipe
very intelligently you gotta remember
caesar's the only guy who can produce
this sad chemical compound stuff that
goes on the black market and is sold to
emperors of the sea like kaido
who uses it to make animalistic
zone-type devil fruit users for his army
now that he has caesar in his custody
daflamingo a main
vendor on the black market that supplies
kaido with all of this stuff
now has his supply cut off and is now at
the mercy of law which he doesn't
appreciate at all
but he has no choice but to do as he
says
[Music]
while i didn't adore this arc like i
normally do with the vast majority of
one piece's stories
i still think that this one was overall
enjoyable despite
its minor misgivings i have with it some
small pacing issues with some wordy
sections ultimately held this one back
from being a standard great arc
which is a shame but as i said there was
a lot to appreciate and enjoy in this
one thanks to this arc i can now say
that i know law's character enough to
actually speak about him for a little
bit
and i love love love his new design but
perhaps my favorite aspect of this
entire story
is that i could feel like it was
building up to something big doflamengo
is a really different and interesting
character to explore
and i genuinely can't wait to jump into
dressrosa next week
however fair warning dress rosa as a
single arc is over 100 chapters long
that is too much for me to cover in a
single video and so i will be splitting
it up into two separate ones
i hope that's all right with you and
with that said comes the end of the
video
i've been totally not mark i'll see you
all next week for dressrosa part 1 and
thank you so much for watching